So we had the first presidential debate this
week, there are still two more debates next
week as the V.P. debate.
But then the week after and the week after
that, we have debates number two and three
between Donald Trump and Joe Biden.
And it turns out that Donald Trump so ruined
the prospects of having an actual debate on
Tuesday night because of his constant, petulant
interruptions that the Commission on Presidential
Debates is changing the rules for the debates
in order to allow an actual adult conversation.
It's just stunning.
They have to account for Donald Trump's childish
behavior, something which, you know, it's
much like the norms that we have established
for presidential conduct.
Many of them, we don't think about what happens
if we have to enforce them because we imagine
we would never have too much like that with
the debate rules.
They now are having to come up with rules
because Donald Trump goes above and beyond
what is normal.
And the Commission on Presidential Debates
has now said, quote, Last night's debate made
clear that additional structure should be
added to the format of the remaining debates
to ensure a more orderly discussion of the
issues.
The commission will be carefully considering
the changes that it will adopt and will announce
those measures shortly now.
Those measures have not yet been announced.
There is a source close to the commission
which says they are thinking about giving
the moderator or someone the ability to cut
off silence or mute a candidate's microphone
when they violate rules.
Like, for example, when Joe Biden was speaking
during his two minutes.
Donald Trump would just keep talking and talking
and talking.
The the issue with that, as far as we've been
told, is both candidates would need to agree
to it in principle.
I can't imagine Trump would agree to it.
Now, the commission could always say the situation
is extenuating and we're putting this this
rule in place, even if you don't agree.
And then it would be up to Trump to either
bail on the debate or to go.
But I assume that there's not too many other
tools you can really think about putting in
place.
And the reaction from Trump campaign communications
director Tim Murda is to disagree.
And he put out a written statement saying,
quote, They shouldn't be moving the goalposts
and changing the rules in the middle of the
game.
Moderator Chris Wallace has been criticized
as if he were the problem.
I think, you know, he did a reasonably okay
job given the tools that he had.
But Chris Wallace says he doesn't think muting
the microphones would really solve the problem.
He said that, quote, Even if the president's
microphone had been shut, he still could have
continued to interrupt.
And Biden's microphone might have picked it
up anyway.
I do think that although that's true, if you
mute Trump's Mike and Biden is talking and
you hear Trump in the background much more
quietly, that just makes Trump look even worse.
And although Chris Wallace is right, in a
sense, I think that that would have been very,
very bad if if Biden is talking in the cameras
on Biden.
But you sort of hear Trump tweeting like a
little bird in the background.
Now, Trump's perspective on all of this is
less nuanced, less sophisticated.
Donald Trump tweeted, quote, Try getting a
new anchor and a smarter Democrat candidate.
They just can't play by the rules.
Trump can't.
His family can't.
They don't play by the rules in any aspect
of their lives.
And they're not playing by the rules here.
Speaking of rules, by the way, you might have
seen video of when Trump's family entered
the debate hall.
Melania, Ivanka, etc.
They were wearing masks, as were the rules
of the debate hall.
But then they just took them off.
When the debate got started and you know that
that's against the rules.
They just sat there.
Marsalis everybody else was wearing masks.
OK.
I mean, I they just don't follow the rules
and there are no repercussions.
Now, the idea I have for this is sort of a
difficult to manage idea because it's logistically
difficult.
But my idea would be if it's Biden's time
and Trump starts talking over him, you pause
Biden's time.
So he doesn't lose any time while while Trump
is interrupting and Trump's interruptions
are deducted from his next answer.
So if Trump interrupts for 20 seconds, Biden
gets an extra 20 seconds.
And in his next answer, Trump loses 20 seconds.
It's very hard to manage in real time.
Trump would absolutely lose his mind.
They would cry about fake news.
Everybody's against them, all of the stuff.
But that's really the only idea I can think
of, which is if you can't stop Trump from
talking.
But you can say we have a total amount of
speaking time here and any that you use now,
you don't get to use later.
It's an idea.
If you have a better one, certainly let me
know.
Now, if you want something approximating substantive
discussion here.
I believe the only real chance at that is
the vice presidential debate next week.
Vice presidential nominee Kamala Harris will
be facing off Wednesday evening against Vice
President Mike Pence.
I believe she's going to crush him.
I think it's going to be just a brutal, brutal
slaughtering of Mike Pence by Kamala Harris.
But let's watch it together.
We will be streaming Wednesday evening live
on YouTube, Twitch and Facebook.
I invite you to join me.
I think it will be very interesting and maybe
we will actually get some policy discussion,
which would be interesting
for
a change.